also mir geht es darum dass das man
gerade in diesen schwierigen zeiten auch
mutige flagge zeigen könnte und sollte
ich meine in kiew die hauptstadt meine
heimatstadt
wurde immer noch nicht um zinggl nicht
an gekreist nicht besetzt die lage
bleibt sehr dramatische und dann die
haut und anderen reporten aus meiner
heimat erfahren viele deutsche über das
leid der menschen sagt tägliche und das
was wir gästen was viele meiner
landsleute erlebt haben war etwas ganz
besonderes nämlich eine reise von drei
regierungschefs aus polen aus tschechien
und auch slowenien mit einem zug nach
kiew um eben flagge zu zeigen haltung zu
zeigen manche haben hier in deutschland
gestern heute das sehr kritisch gesehen
und gesagt ja reine symbolpolitik
meine antwort ist kann sein aber gerade
um den menschen den mut zu geben die
bleiben und das ist nicht nur der
präsident so lenski oder der
bürgermeister von klitschkos sind viele
viele menschen sind über zwei millionen
tiere und kämmerin die geblieben sind
und die nicht bereit sind ihre stadt
aufzugeben deswegen das wäre schön und
wir haben schon vor
einigen tagen hier in diesem studio
darüber gesprochen es wäre schön dass
auch die deutschen mit dabei sind
vielleicht auch der bundeskanzler auch
mal schief besuchen könnte um einerseits
sich selbst diese zerstörungen anzusehen
und auch gefühl zu bekommen womit man
hier zu tun hat es ist keine krise es
ist wirklich der schlimmste krieg auf
dem europäischem boden seit
1945 und was wir erwarten wir erwarten
auch ein mutiges handeln der ampel
regierung um den menschen die bleiben zu
helfen und um der armee die kämpfe zu
helfen mit allem was notwendig ist das
wäre auch das gebot der stunde und damit
könnte man auch den menschen nur geben
dass wir nicht verlieren können dass wir
diesen nicht verlieren werden
also ich glaube dass man das ganz ganz
ganz ganz vielen ausrufezeichen versehen
muss und natürlich muss olaf scholz wenn
er es nicht schon getan hat seine
reiseplanung darauf einrichten und am
besten machte das zusammen mit
herrn makro der hat wahlkampf ich werde
jetzt mal zynisch dazu sagen dass
süchtige womöglich da auch noch also da
gibt es viele gründe und was mir an der
idee gefällt ist sozusagen die eines
menschlichen schutzschildes ja ja ich
glaube es ist die die die
intelligentesten und klügste art sich
jetzt zu verteidigen und ich will noch
mal erinnern dass hier auch aus der
ukraine schon eine einladung an den
papst ergangen ist und ich habe bisher
nicht gehört
was die antwort war die antwort kann
aber nur sein dass der papst dahin reist
wir stellen uns einmal für ein
romantisches
minütchen vor der papst sagt ich nehme
meine sommerresidenz
das ist ein iron dome also iron dome
statt petersdom das wäre ein zeichen
denn dass wladimir putin und die
russische armee eine stadt dem erdboden
gleich macht das stand ja immer mal in
rhede als strategisches ziel in der ist
sozusagen der papst residiert ist nahezu
ausgeschlossen das gleiche gilt
abgestuft auf alle anderen deshalb fand
wenn man überlegt wie kann man
eigentlich als wahrscheinlich
militärisch unterlegen ich will ihre
armeen und den mut der ukrainer nicht zu
nahe treten aber wahrscheinlich muss man
das einmal konstatieren als militärisch
unterlegen sich zu verteidigen
dass man am ende gewinnt oder jedenfalls
nicht untergeht finde ich dieses auf
persönliches engagement von wichtigen
personen gründende engagement sehr sehr
gut oder jetzt werden gleich alle
erschrecken wieso fährt eigentlich nicht
kreta dahin ja und sagt also das ist
zwar wichtig das weltklima noch wichtig
ist aber eine erde ohne krieg und
deshalb sollen alle jungen menschen
dieser welt auf sie gucken wie sie auf
dem majdan jetzt ein sit-in macht warum
findet das alles nicht statt warum ist
das alles nur quasi indirekt das soll
jetzt mal die ukraine erledigen und die
nato unter herbei da gibt es ja noch
viel viel mehr möglichkeiten und wenn
von unserer runde ein impuls ausgehen
würde dass wenigstens der bundeskanzler
dahin fährt werden wir schon schritt war
mein der urlaub schafft es dieser tage
ja nicht mal von der regierungsbank zum
rednerpult zu reisen aber bundestages
gleich sagen leer war ich will noch mal
unterstreichen ich finde es war ein
unglaublich starkes zeichen der drei
ministerpräsidenten kann ja und ich will
auch noch mal sagen ich gehörte nie zu
denen da gab es ganz andere der
bundestag immer den stab auch gebrochen
habe über den polnischen
ministerpräsidenten morath jetzt geht
der zeigt jetzt eben auch wirklich eine
klare haltung an der stelle die
aufnahmebereitschaft die polen im moment
hat diese einsatzbereitschaft auch wie
die sich klarheit wahlgang mit langen
menschen dient uns kommen auch im
übrigen grau registrierung viele
administrative dinge funktionieren da
deutlich besser und da muss ich auch
sagen da gibt es manche die da über
polen und über unsere polnischen partner
glaube ich manches mal den stab
gebrochen haben die sich jetzt
richtigerweise korrigieren müssen ohne
dass da alle politikfelder wo man
überholt ohne jetzt ist aber die art und
weise wie der so paternalistisch
gesprochen wurde das hat mir nicht
gefallen und deshalb verdient jetzt hohe
anerkennung und ich finde auch dass hat
nichts irgendwie mit einem pr thema zu
tun sondern das bild der lebenden
schutzschilde trifft es das ist echt ein
klares zeichen an putin wir wollen mal
auch wenn ich so hart ausdrücken muss
beschreibt nochmal ja panik weil ich
gegen alt ansprechen lag lewis nur
noch eine idee weil wir über so viele
figuren sprechen und nennt mich
vielleicht etwas obsessed aber gaza wäre
denn wenn der beste freund von wladimir
putin sogenannter gas
ausströmt hat recht dass ein hotel
mitten am meisten beziehen würde ich
glaube er könnte damit wirklich sein
image also da hätte ich auch kein
problem damit dass es ihm um pr aber man
das geld jetzt auch weiter anzieht da
gibt es auch ein schönes hotel das
hotel ukraine glaub ich oder euro da
kann er auch seine frau mitnehmen die
kann auch tolle fotos von dort schießt
also in herrlicher blick den habe ich
schon häufiger wahrgenommen dass wir
also jetzt mal ohne witz also wenn
gerhard schröder
sagt ich gehe nach kräften
schröder noch höher als der braven
zurückgeblieben aber nach
einigen sagt er wäre begleitet er wäre
bereit gerhard schröder zu begleiten das
heißt jesus angebot an gerhard schröder
wenig würde sogar
paul nava den händen der spd bleiben
also das habe ich ja nicht zu
entscheiden klaus da gibt es dann
unterschiedliche kommission die darüber
entscheiden muss das ist ja alles
geregelt wie wir wissen aber
ich würde noch interessieren eine frage
genau dazu an den herrn botschafter wie
würde denn olaf scholz jetzt nach kiew
kommt würde der auch mit der eisenbahn
fahren was glauben sie ist ja der beste
weg und wie plant man aus deutschland
momentane reise hier ja also ich glaube
hauptsache dass die entscheidung fällt
das der deutsche regierungschef auch mal
diese flagge zeigt und vielleicht auch
die worte benutzte jemand hier in berlin
im jahre 1948 gehört hat schaut auf
diese stadt ja diese stadt sie ist
bedroht tag und nacht sie beschossen
sie wird vergewaltigt jeden tag und
trotzdem steht diese start und ich
glaube wie man nach gelangt das ist eine
andere sache am besten du dich mit
deutscher bahn bis zur grenze und dann
gibt es auch ukrainische bahn aber wir
haben immer noch ein
wirklich sehr bequem reisen
er würde also genau diese rede die er
dann am besten auch in der nähe des
meiden sondern auch immer hält schaut
auf diese stadt andere manager hätten
sie das für realistisch haben sich schon
mal vorgefühlt im kanzleramt nein aber
ich glaube es ist schon etwas was was
man manchmal braucht man braucht
natürlich vor allem diese unterstützung
die die menschen benötigen die jetzt
aushandeln müssen in schutz brauchen
können in kellern und da seit wochen
aber man braucht auch diese gesten ja
gästen der zuversicht dass dieser staat
nicht untergehen darf dass die ukraine
nicht untergehen darf und darum geht es
heute